[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the data
science hangout and our last data
science hangout of
2023 I know people always say this but I
seriously can't believe that we're
already here at the end of the
year I want to say a a huge thank you to
the 47 leaders who have joined us at the
data science hangout this year thank you
Rachel for
hosting thank you um and those three
sessions where we all were the featured
leaders and who knows if this is
accurate with zoom but the over
2,600 people who have joined us at data
science Hangouts since we've started
them um and the core group group here
who keeps coming back and hanging out
with us each week so thank you all so
much for making this space what it is I
really love getting to spend time with
you
all if this is your first time joining
us today it's so nice to meet you I'm
Rachel I lead customer marketing at
posit if it is your first hangout say hi
to us in the chat because we'd love to
welcome you in as
well this is our open space to chat
about data Science Leadership questions
you're facing and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of data
across different
Industries so we're here together every
Thursday at the same time same place
we'll be on a bit of a holiday break
here for the next few weeks but we'll be
back on January 11th so if you're
watching this recording on YouTube later
and want to add it to your calendar
it'll be in the details below on how you
can join us
live we're all dedicated to making this
a welcoming environment for everybody so
we love hearing from everyone no matter
your years of experience titles
languages you work in or
Industries and it's totally okay to just
listen in here if you're out walking
your dog if you're in a coffee shop or
something U but there's always three
ways you can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own perspective on
certain topics so you can raise your
hand on zoom and I'll keep my eye out
you could put questions in the zoom chat
and just put a little star next to it if
it's something you want me to read out
loud
instead and then we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously um and we'll share that in
the chat here in just a second and I
love
um uh Mike suggestion in the chat here
to get everybody going because we love
the conversation that happens in the
chat but share your favorite holiday
film in there I'm taking my suggestion
from their
fiser hangout
too but with that I'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host today Sean Newan
senior staff data scientist at SG
Ventures and Sean I'd love to have you
jump in here and introduce yourself and
share a little bit about your role but
also something you like to do outside of
work
too yeah so I'm Sean I'm uh First Data
science hire at s2g ventures um we're a
venture capital based company based in
Chicago We're investing in food and
oceans and clean energy companies and so
we were founded in
2017 and I was kind of brought
on um in 2021 as the first data science
hire to kind of flush out the ca
capabilities of of the organization and
my background is in molecular biology
and so um I was really interested in
working in data and then I kind of
learned learned about this thing called
data science and then I I got really
addicted to to learning how to program
and then I kind of took those skills and
took it to s2g and then in terms of
things that I like to do outside of work
um I really like photography and cooking
so I'm a bit of a um person that likes
to try out new restaurants in Chicago
and cook at home so yeah what's one of
your favorite things to
cook um I I like to cook uh different
Cuisines like
um I don't know it depends like what I'm
feeling so sometimes I'll create like
like Tai curry paste from scratch right
and just kind of make that and use it
for different things so I like trying
different Cuisines you know so
yeah well I get to start off with some
of the questions here as we wait for
them to come in from everybody but I
just want to say I loved your posit comp
talk from this year and was just
listening to it a few days ago but I
love when you you spoke a bit about the
POC or proof of concept that you did and
I thought it might be helpful to start
by talking a little bit about that so we
can all get some context into some of
the work that you do um would you be
able to explain a bit about the project
that you came up with to use for your
POC and kind of get buying across the
company for for your project yeah so um
as the the the first data science hire
within the org I knew you know we wanted
to get information to our business units
right and so um what I wanted to do was
run analyses and send it to let's say my
manager right the thing is is that when
I created our markdown document at the
time in order to share it with with her
I had to basically render the the HTML
file and send send it over right because
I didn't have like um a server right cuz
it's proprietary information we can't
share it easily right because you don't
want it out in in the world so I'd send
the email attachment and um send it to
her and then she she would be like oh I
this is great but like I don't want to
download something and have to open it
right so I want to be able to click a
URL link and so in terms of like what it
was what it was was it's kind of an
analysis of anything that she wanted to
know that's like perfect for for for job
right so let's say like here's the
meetings that you have of uh during the
week right and that it's really
insightful information that you can't
necessarily get from let's say a
um
um like a dashboard or something like
that it's super specific to them right
so like in terms of the idea of the PO
is that is to kind of almost give that
nugget of like oh wow this is really
useful to me and then being able to
surface that to them right and then that
what that does is it gets that buy in
because often times when you're trying
to let's say get a new service or a new
product right it they some people will
look at the the sticker price right it's
like sticker shocks like oh wow there's
no way I'm going to pay that we already
have tblo we already have powerbi
whatever like why do I want to get
another you know data science product
I've never heard of so in order to kind
of almost get the Buy in is you kind of
give them that that like oh wow should
the art of the possible right to be like
oh the you know here's this cool thing I
was able to do and then they're like oh
my gosh I really really like that tell
me more and then that's how you can kind
of get them to be like oh this is really
useful because you kind of are servicing
information that's really relevant to
them at that
time right so yeah and I think that's
something that's come up quite a bit on
the Hangouts too um which would be good
to chat a little bit more about is the
communication piece of your insights but
also Al realizing you might need to have
some different approaches like not
everybody's going to go and look at a
dashboard they might need a summary of
insights in an email and I'm wondering
like what lessons have you learned about
that communication
piece yeah so I think the idea of being
able to proactively find information
that might be relevant to people because
like to your point like I can create 10
dashboards and then just be oh check the
dashboards other people they don't have
time to that right and so sometimes you
can be like oh it looks like you're
meeting with you know Mary from whatever
company did you know that XYZ thing
happened right and then that then they
can go armed ready with this knowledge
whenever they meet with this this
individual and they don't have to check
a dashboard right and so being able to
find whatever information whether it be
from a dis a different data source some
analysis or report and then you're able
to kind of send them an email right or
that or some type of alert dynamically
right so I use the blast Shilla package
with an art to kind of send emails
programmatically to people right and so
that's how I was able to get them to to
really like latch on to that because to
your point you know it's it's um people
don't want to necessarily have to check
something right it'd be nice if it was
delivered to you uh in your inbox and
you can be like oh wow this is really
helpful and then you go on your
way shared into the chat the example
that you referenced in um your talk but
Kelly O'Brian at at posit built this
example um where she had like a a cookie
cutter ETS seash shop and she showed how
she used blastula and and posit connect
to send out these conditional emails
it's just a fun example I wanted to
share in the the chat this
great um and I'm seeing lot of love for
blasa here in the chat as well so feel
free to share some oh I think you
already are share some resources on that
too thanks
Marcos um George I see you asked a a
question here in the chat do you want to
jump
in I know it's a question kind of for
the chat as well but I thought it would
be good to discuss live too sure yeah
thanks Rachel um yeah theyve got me
thinking about just um prior prior role
that I had you know and I was wondering
if anyone else had a prior job in sales
and I think the way you put it Sean
where you said you know uh the person
might ask you know I already have this I
already have that why do I need this new
thing like that's
exactly like the kind of sales question
and um like interaction that I used to
have at a in a prior role um but I never
really thought about bringing those
skills here because I was never really
good at it it's not like my my natural
state to try and sell things so just
wondering if like there's any best
practices that maybe people have in
general from being in a like sales role
maybe you sold cell phones maybe you
sold um cars I don't know um but it
seems like it's very important in what
we do yeah I mean I don't have
experience in in sales but I think to
your point I think it's about trying to
find
that the way that you can provide value
I feel like I'm reiterating my talk
sorry so uh it's to find Value that that
the person would be interested in right
and so then you're trying to make their
life a little bit easier right whether
it be you're selling something or you're
you're trying to give
them information in my case information
that allows them to act and you know
kind of do their job a little bit better
without friction right and so at least
with for me it was just building
different um different reports right
that allows them to to to do whatever
whatever they need one one thing I I did
recently just I think on Tuesday so we
do uh I decided last year to uh make a
CTO reveal JS document so a slide deck
of like we call it s2g wrapped like the
Spotify wrapped where I summarized all
the things that we've done um in the
organization and it's like more than
just a PowerPoint deck because it
actually embeds all the different
widgets and dashboards and so I used
like um GT with the interactive
interactivity with it I used
um uh all these different charts from
like High charter and all that and
allows people to kind of interact with
stuff and kind of see everything as a
summary right and it's one of those
things that I got so much good feedback
like oh my gosh this is amazing right
and then um allows allows the folks to
to kind of see like all the work that
we've done um and so that's like one
thing that I I kind of created and I I
would encourage other people to do that
is to use like quto right you can create
an HTML file a PDF or you use like the
reveal JS uh presentation or you can
render it as a PowerPoint as well but it
it allows you to go from just routine
analysis to something that's really
amazing that you can share with uh
people in your community
I love that idea George about like using
that prior experience that people may
have learned in sales and it was just
making me think um I mean I was in sales
at posit before but like one of my first
jobs was actually working um a beer cart
on the golf course and like driving
around in the golf cart and that in a
way was also a sales job but figuring
out different ways you could like go out
of your way to create a better customer
experience like if somebody mentioned
they like needed sunscreen like going to
grab that and like bringing it out to
them um and so it was just kind of like
making me think about like when you're
serving these insights as well and like
figuring out the best way to share that
information so your end user has the
best experience
possible um I always love being able to
tie in like past roles like that and
Lessons Learned but um RM I I saw you
had a comment on that thread too so I
was curious if you wanted to add
anything on that hi thanks uh no not a
whole lot to add but just wanted to say
that sales skills come up in surprising
ways um you know you might have the most
wonderful piece of analysis but you can
convey that to your stakeholders that's
essentially worthless so it's important
to remember no matter how cool your code
is or how powerful your analysis is uh
you still have to sell the thing I know
the sale sometimes is downplayed a
little bit but uh it's an important
skill to have
absolutely yeah for sure I've I've I've
noticed that firsthand right where yeah
you can have the fanciest models or
anything like that but unless you can
Surface it to them and something that's
meaningful to them it's exactly that
that point right where you can have if
it lives was it I think it was David
Robinson right if it lives on your
laptop it's essentially useless right
you need to ship it or send out
something so that people can actually
see it or appreciate it right because
like yeah it's great on your computer on
the code but like will people actually
be able to use it right it's cool that
you know about it but you want to share
it with everyone else right so yeah
absolutely Alan I see you had a question
you want to jump in
here yeah hey everybody um Sean I'm
really curious about how you figured out
as the First Data data role in the in
the org how did you and your leaders and
your peers figure out what like success
would look like for you because on one
hand you've got like this a you've got
some autonomy you can do psc's at some
point you need to figure out like does
that get formalized into you know like
am I successful at my job and I'm
wondering how that what that process was
like for you how did you how did you get
agreement on like okay I think this is
what I do now and people are are you
know happy with that uh what was that
process like how did you figure that out
organizationally so I think it my role
has evolved over time at s2g right and
at first it's just that we were trying
to we had all this information right we
wanted to be able to cuz like at the end
of the day technically with for the
bottom line for s2g is like being able
to invest in Innovative companies and
then hopefully being able to generate
market returns for for the the fund
right at the at the end of the day and
so it was it for us it was clear as like
hey are we driving value for our
portfolio companies because if they're
successful then in the end we will be
successful and so it was clear from for
us is being able to
identify um let's say investors that
would we we would want to co-invest with
or other companies right so it's it was
clear from there like if I'm able to
identify investors or companies that are
relevant to us then therefore it will
help the bottom line of the organization
and and so um in terms of like how I'm
successful so if I'm able to identify or
create different models that allows us
to you know find out a company that's a
diamond in the rough or an investor or
someone that we may not have interacted
otherwise right we allow them to to find
them by doing analyses and things like
that and therefore that's how like I at
least for me I was successful right and
so one way to do that is to be able to
kind of interview the different
stakeholders not necessarily your
manager per se right you you get
guidance from them but then you interv
interview stakeholders identify with
their pain points right it's like oh I I
every time you know I'm I'm scrambling
right before my meeting to find a
talking point points to um whoever I'm
meeting with right so then I was like
okay let's take that take the different
data sources using the contextual
knowledge of like the different data
sources that we have so for us we use
Salesforce other data sources right try
to integrate them and then you know
provide a proof of concept or whatever
and then you drive value there because
then you're able to say like remember
when you went to me and you said I I
have trouble figuring out what I'm going
to talk to about with this person I'm
able to provide that therefore I give
them something that they like and that's
how you can kind of be successful in in
that regard at least for for me right
yeah was just to to follow up a tiny bit
was there anybody who again as the first
role of of the kind was or anybody who
thought you were going to be doing
something different and you had to like
reconcile like oh no I think it's this
and figure it out together for sure yeah
I think yeah we we had different tools
and then I think for me is the I knew
what I wanted to do right but then some
sometimes you can't do that because you
need the like the data Foundation there
right you have duplicate accounts you
have like all there's so much like
things that you need to cleanse and to
be able to run the cool fancy models
which I would love to do but the thing
is is a sometimes the data is not there
it's not clean so it's like getting I
think for me it's like you you you
create the pocc and then you because you
know what you need to do in terms of
cleaning the data get the data sources
and actually make it so that it's use so
that you can do it relent analysis right
so you kind of give them a nugget that
they would like and then on the back end
you kind of fix stuff um and and and
make it cleaner so that you can actually
make you know more feature-rich poc's
but yeah definitely it it's a struggle
right um a getting the buy and to get
the tools to be able to do the thing
that they want um and then kind of
getting to buy in from them but yeah it
it's it's definitely a struggle so but
then you have autonomy I had a lot of
autonomy right so that's like the pros
and cons of like being on a big team
versus you know being the the solo
contributor nice um I know you mentioned
in one of the answers
before like trying to advocate for for
tools when you already have something
like a bi tool but I was wondering do
you also work alongside with the bi
tools or are there any use cases with
that yeah so what I've done recently so
I we had um some bi tools before and but
then what we didn't have was um because
sometimes those tools require
essentially more or less mod model data
layers where it's like pretty clear like
when you're querying from this you're
you feel confident in in the data that
you're you're pulling from in terms of
the rows and things like that um but uh
what I I had to do is I had to create um
ETL pipeline so it's just getting data
from our our raw data sources
transforming them and modeling them so
that they're actually usable and then
that actually feeds our bi tools
Downstream right and so at least for me
we use posit connect to to to have
scripts that take the data do the thing
and then send it back to our our data
warehouse right and then from there our
bi analysts can take the data and do
whatever they need to do and feel
confident about it rather than pulling
from the raw log
right we're able to kind of just point
to they call it a a model data layer
right and so then you you know
confidently with high confidence that
that it what you're displaying is
accurate right so it's it's not like
we're trying to replace one another we
kind of live in in harmony right so I'm
able to take the data clean it and then
run my own analysis but then other
people like other not um Power users
that can use it to run analysis on
themselves and not have to worry about
is this correct or not so thank you
Frank I see you had a question a bit
earlier I want to jump in here um hey
Sean thanks for all your Insight so far
you started talking about modeling and
you mentioned right like building a
model and finding the gems that wouldn't
be seen otherwise and it got me
wondering a lot of this conversation has
been focused on sales or right like how
you pitch data science and the value and
how you get information to the right
people at the right place at the right
time I
the question popped into my head um if
you had to Ballpark it right this is not
a super quantitative answer I'm looking
for but I'm curious uh if you look back
what would you say um you attribute your
success to in right like 50 % is it that
the sales and the operations and how you
how you delivered um data science to
your to your organization uh versus the
modeling and the statistical rigor um
that you do kind of like behind the
scenes in terms of like how like where
do I spend my time or like in terms of
what metrix sorry yeah no uh like what
do you attribute your success to like it
sounds like you've been pretty
successful in your role so if you had to
look back and reflect and say like Oh My
Success right like I do a lot of like
delivery and like selling this to the
organization versus yeah yeah so I would
say it's it's it was a struggle at the
beginning right like there's no doubt
about it of getting all the a the data
getting the model and then we like what
I did was I was able to I would say
maybe spent like I don't know 75% of the
time getting the the value in the sense
that like getting the nugga of
information but it was in like a a
collab notebook right so I had this
machine learning pipeline it was like
essentially White Glove service right
like Sean give me the top you know 100
investors for this company or whatever
right and so I would do the analysis and
run that stuff but then they were like
oh you know what I want someone that's
going to write a $10 million check so
then I have to go in and change it
change it change it so then what I ended
up doing was like okay this is not
scalable we need to productionize this
to a POC like a streamlet application
right so it's like a python app web app
they can kind of do whatever they want
change the parameters do it it's
self-service but I didn't I couldn't do
that until I had like the foundation of
like the model so to speak so it's like
a ton of time went into that
that was not a good use of uh time in
the sense of like tweaking every
parameter for them and so then I was
like okay let's create a web application
and then that was a a beast in and of
itself but then once that's up and
running you're you're kind of you know
smooth sailing from there so it's like
75% and then the other 25% for me was
creating a web application or a you know
some type of widget thing that the end
unit or the business unit could use to
be able to do whatever ever they want
and I I call it productionizing it
because it's like it's no longer in a
notebook but it's an actual app right
and then another caveat is like the
whole deploying like when you're in the
Enterprise you can't just I would love
to just deploy it in GitHub right and
make it open to the world but because
it's proprietary information you have to
that's another like a security thing
getting Buy in from your it people right
CU that's a whole Beast if you're in a
big organization you can't just like you
have to go through all these approval
right so that's another issue as well
and I can talk about it um when I got
connect right because it's I'm not a
Unix a Linux admin and so I had to kind
of deploy it and learn all that stuff as
well right and to be able to deploy it
within so I can just send a link to our
internal uh
connect uh server and then anyone in the
OR can access the web application easily
so if you don't have like the Enterprise
constraints it's actually not nearly as
bad as I'm describing it right right so
there's plenty of uh ways to deploy
stuff freely in uh within GitHub but
there's a huge amount of time building
it a little bit for uh creating the
proof concept like the web application
and then you don't have to deploy it but
then after that it's smooth sailing
because you just update it and push it
and that's that's why I I kind of split
it up like
that it's awesome uh it reminds me of
when people say like if I had x amount
of hours would spend 90% of the that
time understanding the problem like
you're doing that you're understanding
the problem and then once you get that
and you invested all that like building
the thing is is relatively
easy yeah yeah yep definitely so it's a
lot of understand the problem for sure
yeah cool
that I have a
question um how do you bring people I
had a client who um was convinced that
these Bond metrics were just a few
calculations in Excel and it wasn't it
was a big deal how do you bring people
along who are really
uninformed yeah so I think it is it is
tricky right I think like um sometimes
you'll
see um you you'll at least for me I
you'll run analyses and then it'll be
like almost like confirmation of like oh
yeah I knew that all along right but
like sometimes at least for for for me
we'll have someone I'll list that
investor that you know the managing
director had knew about but didn't it
wasn't off the top of their head right
and then for them they like oh wow that
is interesting and then that's that's
that's relevant to us but in terms of
like different calculations yeah I think
in in your field is there is there
instances in which a value or some type
of piece of information that's surfaced
that wouldn't necessarily be like um
remembered off the top of their head or
or is it do you think it's just more of
an understanding of like what's the nuts
and bolts of like how you get to that
answer I think it was I think it it's
it's like you know calculate prices and
yields and duration and
and and what happens if you change the
sensitivity to yield changes and prices
so it it isn't stuff off the top of the
head maybe now that I've done it it'll
be more on top of my head but um um he
ended up stiffing me and not paying me
at all so oh no I was really really
pissed didn't our markon had had the
code for him everything oh geez that's
that's a bummer I'm sorry yeah well so I
want to get better so it's like uh the
whole thing
was convincing him that doing this work
was more complicated than he
thought that's that's what I need the
skill that's that's where I didn't do
well oh no I'm sorry about bad yeah
sometimes like I think like in order to
to to find that that that ability to
impress the folks is sometimes you kind
of show like what is the normal route or
the path of in which they they get their
answers and then you can kind of show
yours um but in your case it's a little
bit tricky right or almost like yeah
like a almost like a chart right it's
like here's how how you normally do it
this is how long it takes here's how my
Approach will take it's more accurate
cheaper better faster whatever right and
then at least allows them to kind of see
that uh for me what I on my end of year
um things I'll say like oh I helped
automate a process right that would take
our analyst you know maybe 30 hours of
work and I just run I run the script and
it just it runs right and so then I can
say I'm saving the organization let's
say 120 hours every year that they can
do other things right and through code
so that's how at least you almost kind
of take the numerical approach and
quantify uh of what you're you're doing
to to kind of sell yourself or like what
you're doing to provide the customer um
value is what I found and and part of
the story was to convince somebody that
having re a reproducible research is a
good idea as for a few calculations so
that's another thing to sell yeah yeah
for sure
you had a question about like kind of
like a followup to nany's question but
also some thoughts to share here do you
want to jump
in no worries if you prefer to Poe in
the chat but I just wanted to let you
know Nancy it looks like a lot of people
are weighing in in the chat as well
okay um I also wanted to add just to let
everybody know if I miss anybody's
questions in the chat I don't have my
posit co-host here co-hosts here today
so just feel free to raise your hand if
there was anything I missed so that so
that I know but thank you so much I see
Darren you just asked a question you
want to jump
in oh I was not expecting that quick a
response sorry just saw it first um John
I was curious you had uh
mention uh um in your discussion your
experience working with it
and um having to do your own ETL
pipelines being the solo data scientist
in your organization and that can be a
lot for just an individual person
especially someone kind of starting out
in data science so I just kind of wanted
to know more about your your path and
understanding who to talk to and how to
get the resources you needed to be
effective and you know do what you want
to
accomplish yeah so you asking more of
like how how I implemented posit connect
and work
uh within the order I mean not
necessarily it's just just as a data
scientist there's so many things that
you know individual feel like they have
to learn and on top of that there's this
it side of things that they may not be
familiar with and um and and just
understanding how data pipelines work or
how data flows work and that's a whole
other area that you know some data
scientists may not be exposed to yeah no
so truthfully I think like I I was kind
of self-taught right and so I didn't
know any better right so a good example
is
um learn Learning How okay so I have
data that's like duplicate in Salesforce
like how can I make it so I can't dup it
easily right and so then I created some
scripts that um would dedup it on a
nightly basis but then to your point
like I need to be able to let's say I
have connect or some type of process to
automate it right making sure you have
Buy in U from your it folks and
sometimes with organizations you are
really restricted right to be able to
even access the database it's like
sometimes you can't even get that right
and at least for for me I was fortunate
enough in that we were kind of building
out our our Cloud infrastructure so I
had a little bit of a hand in that but I
by no means knew like what was up um I
think I talked about in my in my connect
talk for posit that I I I was trying to
update the server and I totally bked the
the image right and so luckily I backed
it up and so right now our production
image is like the our studio connect
back up like that's what we use in
production now right because I don't
know any better right and so it's just I
I think it's kind of having that
mentality
to
to be able to move quickly and to kind
of iterate and then know that you're
going to make mistakes but then I think
it's highly dependent on your your it
infrastructure right and then being
communicative right so sometimes like
their job is to make sure everything's
secure and to not you know not have data
leakage or anything like that and so
making sure that you're on the same team
right to be like hey look I'm trying to
we're on the same team we're trying to
provide value to the organization and
understand like what are their concerns
right and and then that you're not going
rogue because i' what I've experienced
is that that's not not fun for anyone
right um but in terms of for my
experience in it I think we we had some
Consultants that helped us
um um spin things up and then making
sure that you had weekly or monthly
meetings during the implementation phase
so that everyone knew what was going on
and then like you as you work with
different uh departments you kind of
earn that trust right and then trust I
think at least in the Enterprise that
I've experienced helps you get of way
further than trying to do it all on your
own um but I think it is kind of Highly
dependent but I that's the the
experience that I've had that's worked
out
well definitely hiccups though so thanks
sh
y thank you so I I've had this come up a
bit recently but I think sometimes
people see like stories about data
science and huge companies or teams with
tons of data scientists and think like
that's so far from something that could
be possible for my team if we have one
person or three people um some of my
favorite stories are when I get to hear
about like superpowers that connect
gives smaller teams but this does not
have to be a connect focus at all I'm
just curious if you could share with us
like some of the use cases where you
think people could start making an
impact right away if they're a smaller
team yeah so I think uh for for me being
able to host web applications whether
whether it be streamlit shiny um or you
know uh other like flask applications
securely because that's like a big
hurdle within at least for me is like I
can't share it publicly right and so one
of the quick wins for me is being able
to host whether it be a a quto document
so or like are I I host look at Apple
like doing all the level thing they do
this is like the look at that see
sorry it enables it so it allows you to
be able to
host things quickly right and and so
that people can access it in a secure
environment um and then the and then you
were asking uh
sorry yeah no I guess I was saying like
not necessarily connect specific but
just some of the like business use cases
where people could start make helping to
make an impact right away I think
helpful sometimes even if we're all
working across different Industries to
just get an idea of ways people are
impacting the business and yeah yeah
yeah so like a good example is some
creating basically like a I I was
helping one of our analysts out I I made
a way to like a pivot table essentially
but like where they just upload whatever
CSV that they want and it automatically
would do it for them it was like a quick
thing that I did for them that made
their life so much easier right and it
because it would take me time to kind of
do it I was like you know I don't want
to repeat myself over and over so then I
basically have and still it's to this
day it's like this little pivot table
thing that'll automatically do whatever
they need to do whether it be cropping
photos for people right it's just like a
little small toy example that does one
thing and it and it's actually quite
helpful right because then it's frees up
my time makes them a little bit easier
um it's one of those things that that I
think it it doesn't have to be complex
because I think you know you know even I
thought so I wanted to have the most
sophisticated app that has all the it's
like a Ferrari right but you don't need
that you just need something simple
right just if it does one thing and it
does it well and robustly people will
begin to use it over and over and over
right and that's kind of it's It's so
funny it's like I was so proud of this
app that I made but it's like the the
simple thing like the pivot tables like
people like that right and it's like
whatever it's it's cool it did not take
me nearly as long right but sometimes
it's those little small things that it
does it well and that's what you know
can get people um really excited about
whatever you're you're
producing I love that how do you find
out like what those things are that are
taking people way longer than it should
or the opportunities to help somebody
yeah so I think it's just one of those
things where it's like pattern
recognition where someone has come to
you like more than three times to do
this one thing because you do it well
it's very simple um whether it be duping
or looking up or aggregating it's like
for for us we want to aggregate our
quarterly you know metrics or kpis and
so if do that a couple times you're like
you know what maybe maybe we should make
this into a little self-service
application so that they can kind of do
whatever they want they can kind of
tweak things and then they'll be they'll
be able to get out um the analysis that
that they need right and so it's just
kind of that another David Robinson
think don't do it more than three times
right then create a function but in this
case if you do something maybe create a
a shiny app or whatever app that can
help them do whatever they need to do
more
efficiently yeah cool thank you Kevin I
see your your comment here in the chat
um about having a a repository of these
simple apps can you would you mind just
sharing a little bit more about what
you'd like to see there are you thinking
like example companies or yeah no I was
just thinking that uh you
know that I think think that's a great
like the pivot table thing you know I
think I think there are these like these
things that that nonp power users you
know and end up having having trouble
doing and across lots of Industries it's
probably the same there's probably you
know a handful of tasks that that people
across all Industries are doing in Excel
um that could be done you know through
with with a nft web app you know and
yeah I mean it might be yeah it was I
was just thinking it would be cool if uh
if an organization like posit you know
has access to all of all of us you know
if somehow yeah I'm not sure how
we'd prioritize them because it wouldn't
be helpful if you have a library of like
a thousand web apps that do like all
sorts of crazy things you know but but
if somehow you know it was it was
curated you know really really well you
know then like for example this pivot
table app that Sean's talking about you
know we could probably all use that and
if it's like a shiny app or something
everyone with with a posit server could
just download it from GitHub and spin it
up you know and and and try it so um
yeah I just that that was the idea but
again it would take some curation which
would be tricky um but it could be
valuable if it's done
right yeah I love
it yeah I'm learning from all of you and
when we're talking about building
business cases I need to have these
examples where now I can say look Kevin
from FDA asked about
this gotta go do
it but but seriously if there are
different apps like this or examples
that you you all are thinking of you're
like oh I have one I maybe could
contribute that would help me in
building a case for something like this
so I I started a a thread in the chat if
anybody wants to comment in
there okay awesome let me jump to
scrolling up some of the questions so R
RM I see you asked a question about
working with it do you want to jump in
here and ask
that uh sure thanks uh just uh following
up a thread that was mentioned earlier I
was wondering you have any tips or
tricks or things that work for you when
talking to it a common problem that I've
seen is it doesn't really talk data
science a data time it do you have to
learn key Concepts like what is a server
how do you secure it like basic stuff
like that that you may or may not know
or controver do you have to teach uh it
here this is what ETL this is what it
does here why data is not clean I'm
curious to know what tips and tricks uh
you know you might suggest or you think
that might have worked for you yeah I
think for me um understanding whatever
protocol that they use right at least
for us who remember I'm not like a cloud
U security guy uh learning that we use
OCTA right and making sure that all the
things that we we um had were secured
via SSO right um when we were were
spinning up posit connect within our
organization making sure that we had
OCTA authenticate everything and making
sure that using like the keywords or
Buzz words that they they identify with
because to your point I don't
necessarily speak it natively right all
the like the security and then
conversely they don't speak data science
necessarily right but to make sure it's
like hey I understand this is a high
concern for you and I I share that as
well and here's what we've done to
address that does this sound reasonable
to you
right and so like almost meeting them
where they are is is quite helpful even
though you may not speak exactly the
same language right so like my like my
understanding with OCTA and all that is
like you know we're using that as as the
gatekeeper to authenticate everything
and once you you use that and you're
compliant then it people were were
relieved right or like okay this is good
but then I think your mileage may very
depending on the organization I don't
know how it's like like the FDA right I
don't know things like that um
uh in terms of like how how how how it
is right so it's it is context dependent
but in terms of the the general tips
that I found that that helped me out was
like communicating meeting them you know
even if you know it's like it's secure
like making sure that they understand
that you're not trying to go around them
right um to to do that right thank you
that makes
sense thank you I see a few anonymous
questions want to go over to as well and
um one
was it says thanks a lot can you share
how you tackled data silos and access
company data sources did you handle it
alone or seek support from other
teams yeah so data silos can exist I
think it that's um for me it's like for
it was not necessarily data silus
because all of our our stuff is in the
cloud so we use Google Cloud for for
Google PL platform for our stuff but for
me it was data was siloed in the brains
of like the business unit where and so
what we've done is do informational
interviews where you kind of you you you
go you tag along with them right to kind
of see like how do they go about doing
their job right and so by going to let's
say the business development team or the
investment team and kind of shadowing
them you understand their either their
pain points or like what they can what
you can do as a data scientists to kind
of help make their job uh easier right
and so that's kind of what what I had to
do to to understand that oh they're
really looking for this information and
it is there it's just maybe not easily
accessible to them right and so that's
how you do that because at least for for
me all the data is in like big query and
all the because we we feed everything
into the data warehouse and then we do
all the Transformations and send it back
to like a clean layer right but in order
for me to know what to extract because
there's so much raw data right uh you
almost have to understand what is the
business trying to achieve right because
sometimes I've done things all the time
where I I do stuff that's what I think
is like addresses what they need but
it's not exactly what they they want
right it's like they they may ask for
ABC but they really need DF right but
you don't realize that until you kind of
talk to them even though they say I want
ABC they really need thef and you don't
get that until you're actually to kind
of uh understand things um because like
we we are working with everything but um
that's that's what I've noticed is like
you deliver what they ask for but not
necessarily what they need if that makes
sense right so it's like you only get
that by kind of iterating understanding
uh where data may be or whatever problem
that they're trying to solve in terms of
a silo and then you'll be able to
integrate it that way but I I I I
realize that that may not be the case
because some inst some Enterprises have
true data silos where it's like a
totally different server one is on Prem
one is in the cloud one you don't have
access rights to if it's like healthcare
data so I I can't speak to that but I
can at least speak to to my
experience how do you figure out more
quickly what they actually need if it's
not what they told you they want yeah so
I you know because I you know I was in
grad school I was I'm used to working
late hours and just working on it for
just Brute Force figuring it out but I
what I had to realize when I pivoted the
industry is being able to iterate
quickly to be able to show them like a
janky looking Report with some number
it's like it's like is this right is
this not right is this like in the
ballpark and then getting feedback or
directionality because you know I I do
like that um like the shiny well
polished application but it's like it'll
get to that thing where you you work on
it but then it's like they're like this
is not what I wanted right and so you're
better you're much better off showing
something that's really rough but it's
somewhat tangentially relevant to them
and then iterating again then to like
take all the time make it super
beautiful looking but it's like not the
values of the information that they want
right um so that was kind of one thing I
had to kind of unlearn when I was in
graduate school to to the industry is
like to um to make sure you're getting
feedback from them yeah
that's great thank
you Alan I think you have a question in
the chat also a comment so I'll just
have you jump in I wasn't reading it all
yet oh no I I don't want to be the my
question is more of a comment guy no no
not at all I just can't use both parts
of my brain I think I think I have two
competing things going on in my brain
one of which is I love the idea of the
like pivot table use case and all it
opens up of making nimble flexible ad
hoc tools that really meet a meet a
business solution and I love that
because it's elegant and it's EXC an
exciting way to work and at the same
time I think it competes with push back
about like proliferation of solutions
and uh a different venue a different
avenue of doing work which would be like
saying hey the analyst has just got to
get better at RBI or or or whatever
right and so I'm really curious about
what are the stories to tell that
motivate the kind of work that we all
really really super love versus that
other that other story um and so I'm
just I'm curious if Sean if you or if
others have that success story that
motivates that way to work as opposed to
the like well no you use the Enterprise
bi app Channel way to work um uh because
I think those are in somewhat tension um
yeah I totally agree I think um at Le
for us because we're a little bit
smaller right uh we don't have that
problem yet but I can definitely
Envision this being something that is if
you have like a larger team where it
yeah to your point the analysts or
whoever should get more proficient but
in my at least for my instances it's
it's our admin that needs that just
wants a quick calculation to get to get
on to do whatever they need to do but I
think it's that's one of those things
where at least for me if it's in Connect
you can kind of look at the uses usage
metrics and theoretically look at logs
right to kind of see like oh maybe this
person and and I think you have a
conversation right it's like okay it
seems like you this is really valuable
to you and then you can kind of address
like maybe they need to get better but I
think you got to be strategic about that
you don't want to be like logging
people's activity but I think one
another instance is let's say you have a
suite of really small toy shiny apps or
whatever for pivot tables and all that
you can almost making that like featured
application that allows them to do
whatever they need to do so let's like
they need to Pivot they need to crop and
they need to I don't know make sure the
data is not missing right you can almost
package that into a larger application
that allows them to do that um but I I I
do I do see your point about like there
is a time and a place to use the
Enterprise preferred uh business
intelligence tools right um and that's
tricky for sure yeah
yeah one anonymous question was can you
share how you developed the intuition as
a data scientist or statistician to make
certain
decisions intuition yeah I think for you
kind for me you get the like that code
sensor like that that you get the
inkling for me um what the business
would want right and then from there
it's kind of testing the water so what I
do is I have f folks that aren't
necessarily the super senior managers
but I have the junior level people that
are in the in you know working on the
business and I will send them little
Snippets of like projects work Works in
progress right and then I almost use
them as a barometer of like am I in the
right direction and then if it is then
we kind of go there so that's like when
I did the s2g wrapped right I went to a
couple of our Associates and I was like
hey what do you guys think of this does
this look and feel right because um
sometimes when you're presenting to
management if the values are off they're
gonna like why is this off why is this
right and so you kind of you go to the
people that are a little bit more Junior
and you ask them like hey does this feel
right does this seem right does it not
and what would you want on like the next
slide or whatever right and so then you
kind of use them to be able to guide
yourself uh on producing uh different
applications or or products what product
data products thank you um um Kevin I
realized I missed a question from you
earlier about um getting feedback from
stakeholders do you want to add
anything there or was that yeah sure
yeah I think I think um it's the
question my question really I want to
ask like how do you manage like the the
kind of long-term Vision right when when
maybe the management doesn't you know
really know what's possible and they
yeah I I find I find myself in this
position sometimes where I'm I'm trying
to figure out how to like where
long-term we want to prioritize and and
build things but the management doesn't
really know what's possible and so it's
hard to get from them like what would
they
prioritize you know like yeah how do how
do you kind of get priorities from
management that's that's not in in touch
with um with what's possible if that
makes sense no for sure I think you know
what I've done right is I do whatever we
uh is is asked of me right so let's say
it's like the XYZ kpis you do that but
then sometimes I'll work on a side
project and at least for me I was doing
like a relational graph Network this
year for rap and I kind of slipped that
in as like a little thing like I think
this is pretty cool they're going to
think it's relevant and you do
everything you're not going rogue per se
but you're just adding that little oh
look at this cool thing right and then
you kind of and you try to find the most
not shiny but like more like interesting
thing if you can and insert it and then
you that will peque their interest right
and then they'll ask you for more and
then you almost kind of get that
permission to oh that was just something
I spun up you know last afternoon right
and then they're oh yeah let's do that
right so it's kind of like the indirect
way of doing and I'm not advocating for
like disobeying any your manager or
anything like that but like what I'm
saying is you know they may not know
what's possible right and so what we're
trying to do is show them like hey this
might be possible would you like me to
spend more time on this right and you're
still do whatever you need to do right
that's the the beauty of having code is
like you're able to use something and
recycle it and improve it but then at
the same time you can kind of work on
other things and maybe slip that in and
then get them to to buy in and so that's
like truthfully that's that's basically
the journey that I've been been been
going on is like I knew what I wanted to
do but like there's certain things that
need to be in place in order to do that
right so if I wanted to do a graph
Network I got to make sure the data is
correct right
yeah get some way to surface it to them
and then do that and then so then you
you do those things and then you kind of
slip it in once all those prerequisites
are
met no and my question is less about
yeah getting per giving yourself
permission to do that because I toally
get that yeah you got to do it uh and
show them right but it's more like just
really big picture like how do you how
do you get input on the vision casting
for that when you know because because
obviously you can make your own vision
of what you know you think this graph
thing you have a whole vision for it and
and you can go forward with that and
that's awesome um but ideally when
you're working for an organization you
do want to somehow get input or some
direction from you know from the
leadership um and not just always be
steering them
yeah yeah I think it's one of those
things where you you try to have that
open conversation with the management
and where you're getting like oh what do
you think about next year us creating
like uh an s2g chatbot or where we're
using like a lang chain llm type stuff
and you know they may not necessarily
understand be like oh a chat GPT for the
organization right and so then they're
like ah yes we would love that right and
it's almost kind of like you know it
depends on your relationship with the
management as well like I yeah no that's
really helpful having a conversation
would be like you know let's let's just
brainstorm what we call like you know at
least my relationship with the
management is like that where you can
kind of like hey hey what do you think
about like a chbt for the org right like
it's going to be a huge effort like
don't get me wrong but like you're
you're having a conversation like is
this something worth pursuing is this
not um and then from there you kind of
understand their priorities as well but
I I acknowledge it's that may not be the
case for for some people I would imagine
the FDA you can't just Walt up to the
the administrator right but you know um
trying to understand and meet with the
the decision makers and kind of ask them
about the vision and slip some you know
would something like this be useful or
not is like what I was thinking I don't
know yeah I think the brainstorming
approach makes sense yeah that's good
thanks
man love it well thank you all so much
for joining us today and for all the
Hangouts that you've joined us in in
2023 thank you so much Sean for for
sharing your experience all us today as
well yeah thank you for having me
everybody wishing everybody a great
holiday and we'll see you all back in
the new year so we'll be back on January
11th uh with mein from TD Bank um and I
I've been listening to a lot of podcast
lately where they do their credits at
the end and they realize they don't do
that here so I do want to say thank you
as well to all the people from posit who
make the data science hangout happen uh
you may notice I occasionally have a
different co-host on helping me so thank
you to Hannah Tyler Robert Curtis and
Katherine who will jump in to do that as
well as our creative team who helps us
make sure we get these recordings up and
the upcoming speaker list so thank you
to Olivia Maya green and Margaret but
have a great holiday season and a happy
New Year
everybody thank you thank you all thank
you all take
care